part of what keeps people sane is
healthy social dynamic and the ability
to pay attention to cues and that might
be particularly true for children i was
reading a book the other day
i fortunately don't remember the name of
it i didn't read much of it but
it was written by an anthropologist who
spent some time in more tribal societies
watching how they raised children
well in some sense they didn't
the children went off and played
and so they socialized each other
and
that's
a good example of how
sanity emerges from social interactions
is that is are you implying that that's
better that that dynamic is better i
know that your thoughts on raising
children include like you know as few
rules as possible as little discipline
as possible which seems i wouldn't say
as little discipline but rules
okay you know there well there's a good
rule for rules which is don't multiply
rules beyond necessity
because bad rules drive out respect for
good rules
and the cost of a rule is enforcement
so every time you add a rule well you
add the necessity of enforcement
so
there are minimal you know you want a
minimal set of necessary rules
and then you need to enforce them but
generally
children socialize each other there's
there's very good evidence for that
apart from this book which as i said i
had just begun to read
um
children who are
aggressive at two
so there's a subset of children who are
quite aggressive at two they are
aggressive by nature by all appearances
um
most of them are socialized by the age
of four
and if they're socialized by then they
develop peer relationships that are
strong and then that carries them along
their peer relationships so in some
sense the job of a parent is to
socialize children well enough so that
they can have friends
how do you do that
well
one of the rules i laid out in the first
book i wrote was don't let your children
do anything that makes you dislike them
and that's i suppose part of
self-awareness i mean you might say well
i'd never dislike my child it's like
yeah right
come on
come on no that doesn't mean you don't
love them although you know now and then
you might feel that you don't love them
too
but certainly
you're going to dislike them momentarily
for things that they're doing or not
doing well
you know if you don't like them what
makes you think someone else will
and then you might say well that's just
me you know that's just you you're just
one person well
you're the closest thing to a
representative of the social community
that they have so they're stuck with you
and then i would also say well it'd
probably be better if there were two of
you
you know
father and a mother
because then you can
try to make sure that both of you add up
to one sane person so the child can
interact with that one sane person but
you know it's definitely the case that
i mean i've seen children who don't have
anyone to play with because they don't
know how to play
they're not socialized it's horrible and
they fall farther and farther behind all
the time because
do you think that falls on is that is
that a parent thing is that maybe being
a household
of you know not having a mom and a dad
there children who are fatherless do
worse there's no doubt about that and no
one likes to say that but the
research evidence is crystal clear
and it's hardly surprising i don't know
why anyone would find that surprising
first of all
it's too much work to raise children by
yourself
especially if you have to work
so in that case you're not going to
raise them by yourself anyways you're
going to have other people help you but
you know it's likely the case that the
nuclear family is the minimum
necessary social arrangement for raising
children and it's it's possibly not
sufficient
you know we also don't know what's
happened to children because they don't
have very many siblings anymore
and siblings really in some sense
socializing they certainly help take the
narcissism out of you
um
right because siblings they don't let
each other get away with
being
being narcissistic essentially they're
they're very very uh unhappy about
special attention
so we don't know how many
children children have to have around in
order to be socialized properly
i suspect we're airing on the side of
not enough now and probably not enough
for parents
does it
it seems but is it the case that
narcissism is becoming more and more and
more common
i really don't know it's very very
difficult to answer questions like that
because we just don't have reliable
measures across
generations
you know it isn't obvious to me that
young people today are more narcissistic
than young people were in the 60s
so you know
it wasn't obvious to me when i was
teaching university that the students
were more narcissistic than they were
when i started teaching
but but like i said fundamentally it's
it's it's hard to get an accurate
measure of something like narcissism and
then to track it over decades you don't
even know if the measure itself shifts
i do believe that they're
that people are more lonesome than they
were they're more socially isolated but
you know
that's also very difficult to
determine yeah i'm loath to make
intergenerational comparisons you know
because
every generation thinks that this
current young generation is worse than
any generation that's ever existed and
it's like when you when you grow up and
you listen to your you know your parents
listen to your music and they're like
this stuff's awful and then that
continues on every generation like that
stuff's awful that the kid or listen
kids are listening to
it's like no matter what there's always
this idea that oh it's the worst than
ever
and so maybe that leads to that question
which is
what is better and what is worse than
ever
right now in our culture
i guess it depends to some degree on
your scale
so globally
in terms of economic
uh and absolute economic security
it's better than it's ever been by a
huge margin for everyone
so
there's a much smaller proportion of
people who are without food and water
and sanitary facilities
technology and education
and immunization and health care and
basic living standard and
it's it's and that's a huge amount of
that's
developed in the last 30 years
and almost all of it is developed in the
last 150
despite the fact that the population has
exploded to a tremendous degree
and so
from the perspective of absolute
privation things are better than they
ever have been
in the west
well that's hard to say too isn't it i
mean there's all sorts of opportunities
that there weren't the technological
explosion has produced a tremendous
increment in wealth in some ways i mean
you have more computational power in
your
phone than
nasa used to send people to the moon and
back
and it's basically free now it's not
free but fundamentally the cost is
plummeted to such a degree that
so and we have this tremendous
communications technology
there's a kind of instability i think
that wasn't there
20 years ago
and i think it's a consequence of rapid
technological change
it seems to me and that's possibly
because i'm old